you you've you've been in politics way
longer than I have when did you start
noticing this this shift happening in
the left losing their minds ugh that's
tough I mean I guess in the last four or
five years I would see positions
that were out there on the left and I
would just dismiss them because I I
thought that's nonsense no one I know
really would believe that or do that
um like the whole like the first time I
remember hearing the phrase dead white
men and the culture created by dead
white men or the phrase toxic
masculinity I would just think well
that's ridiculous those are ridiculous
Concepts you know why how can you
possibly take seriously dismissing great
works of art masterpieces our whole
cultural heritage because of the gender
and race of the person who did it that's
racism and that's sexism obviously and
it's also self-destructive and as a mom
of a man and a stepmom of a
11 year old future man
um I really you know object to this
phrase toxic masculinity or nonsensical
statements about like male sexuality
heterosexuality being innately you know
abusive or exploitive
um those are very damaging things to say
to young men and boys and they're
they're also just destructive because it
doesn't have to be that way and it you
know wears love and wears you know this
ideal of people finding each other if
they happen to be heterosexual that
shouldn't be any you know less valid
than any other sexuality that people
want to be
um so but I didn't take those seriously
but once like Victory is so bad for us
on the left it's so toxic for us to win
because once we won
um you know the the presidency and the
house it was like a scary Marxist flood
that was like latent and dormant very
much influenced by the CCP I am I am
convinced and the world economic form
and other Bad actors Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation but this this latent
Marxist stalinist
aggressive violent coercive flood of
nonsense just um erupted and and now
people on the left have no qualms about
being as as coercive and oppressive as
they want to be I like posting on uh I
got a lot of Occupy Wall Street people
who follow me and I like posting on
they'll post things like Trump has been
raided by the feds they'll laugh with
smiley faces and I'll be like my
response to them is always I'm glad that
you finally came around to supporting
the feds and the federal government
right it took you a long time to realize
they were the good guys absolutely and
then the response was like well I mean
it's different hey keep cheering them on
man keep cheering them on because we
know where this goes when did they stop
having like the kantian imperative of it
it has to be consistent if you don't
want them to shut you down and censor
you you can't censor project Veritas you
can't if you don't want them to come for
your present you can't go for their
president why don't they see that would
you say that they feel like they have
the moral High High Ground the things
that project project Veritas are doing
while they may be structurally similar
you know it's another form of censorship
to oppress them it's worth oppressing
because they are promoting the wrong
things well you're a thousand percent
right
um and it's again super scary because on
the left there's been this Mission creep
of language increasing you know what I'm
going to say right yeah increasingly
identifying thoughts as violence or
speech as incitement
um such that it it and January 6th with
a big
part of this like such that I think the
left really feels like the people who
disagree with them are so dangerous and
all white supremacists and you know the
things they think are so innately
violent off before the thoughts and gets
there we can't expose any of this
material to anyone because they might
indoctrinate someone else AKA get them
to think about an issue in a way that we
don't believe in that's really and sorry
oh it's the fear that if Trump becomes
president he's gonna make America like
America autocracy is he gonna he's gonna
make it totalitarian because you they're
using the FBI to kick down doors right
now like what are they afraid is going
to happen I mean they're afraid
someone's gonna kick their door down
from New York so we both it's the
Northeast are here right right okay so
truly the left believes and I used to
believe a lot of this I really did
because they lie to us Legacy Media lies
to us and liberal media lies to us um
I'm not saying the right is perfect or
doesn't distort but these are the kinds
of things the left truly believes that
if Trump were elected or there was
another right-wing or conservative
president uh it would be like Margaret
Atwood's
um handmade
the one reference we can't get over as a
society right Harry Potter right um and
and and that uh that every conservative
is racist every conservative want is is
homophobic um and that it would be kind
of a bible-based reactionary
um America in which religious minorities
would be quashed in which
um there would be no freedom to love uh
there would be a fossil fuel orgy
leading to the demise of the planet in a
matter of weeks is this fair I mean is
there more you want to add that totally
that women would be forced to conceive
and raise children you know that they
didn't want or that they couldn't take
care of
um and you know there's some there's
some truth to these concerns but in a
functioning Civil Society you talk these
things out and you create policies that
you know mean I I don't believe them
because in any system like they may
actually have broken World Views that I
can believe but this idea that the right
is simultaneously advancing fascism
while trying to give you guns makes no
sense like quick everybody have us any
go I I argued that the Second Amendment
does cover nuclear weapons not that it
should cover nuclear weapons but during
the time of the founding fathers you
could have a privateer you could have a
frigate you could have grape shot you
could have full you know a plethora of
cannons the same armaments the
government had that that never changed
so my my point was perhaps people would
agree you should not allow this and we
would need to make that Amendment they
all got really angry that I'd bring it
up my my point here why were they angry
if you don't mind my ass well they
called me like a wing nut arguing that
people should have nuclear people sounds
terrible they didn't misinterpret it
medium matters
you said people should have nuclear
weapons according to the Second
Amendment they thought he meant I think
morally people should have nuclear
weapons were you saying illegally
according to the rule right now people
should be able but but just my point
right now is
uh I'll tell you I'll tell you a story I
was in Berkeley during the battle for
Berkeley when all the antifa were
fighting the Trump supporters and I
actually got to talk to an interview guy
after everything was calming down
because I was just standing there like
you know and this guy said I asked this
anti-fogotic what happened and he said
they came up and they punched my friend
and then we started talking and he told
me that he brought a knife that he was
going to defend himself and then he said
and I asked him why and he said because
these are fascists man they want they
want to kill people and I said you think
all of those people in that Park are
fascists right there and he's like yeah
dude they're all fascists and I said do
you think that those people in that Park
want to defend the Second Amendment and
he was like well yeah of course the
right always talking about guns and I
was like do you think that they would
then care if you had guns like no I'm
like so you think they're fascists but
they want you to have guns right and he
was like uh
and I'm like yeah I I don't get your
logic there's no logic there it's just
tribalism right
it is but also a horrible thing has
happened in the last 10 or 15 years in
America in which these two groups never
get to talk to each other and I think
social media has really escalated that
because the algorithm makes sure that
you only you know you're fed further and
further to one side of the spectrum or
the other there is like I want to see a
YouTube video with someone you don't
agree with in back in the day you could
make a video response and we had
incredible conversations in 2007 but
Google's taken away the video response
really mechanic for oddly but wow but I
want to respond I mean the meme is that
Ben Shapiro is screaming debate me like
people on the right are adamantly saying
come have the conversation I mean we had
Larry Elder on this show and he was
talking about how he's invited all of
these people and they won't come and
talk to them we I mean we talked about
this on the way up Tim you know I run
into this as an editor of of daily cloud
and it breaks my heart we on the left or
we liberals I'll say we're supposed to
be the ones who believe in free speech
remember the Free Speech movement in
Berkeley that was led by the left Mars
was on the left we're supposed to
believe in
um you know not believing censorship
Alan Ginsburg you know like Lady
Chatterley's Lover these are liberals
but now I I you know I'll have people
will send me right leaning op-eds and
I'll reach out to all of my remaining
liberal contacts or just you know put
out the word we go to niral and say will
you please tell us you know why this
pro-life op-ed is wrong right your own
op-ed and they won't do it or we'll go
to the green
um Advocates and say tell us why this
profiles will feel op-ed is wrong and
they won't do it they'll just say you
shouldn't run that material I'm not
going to be appearing a a document where
other people who hold these views appear
I'll give a shout out to Jacob and are
you familiar with Jackman magazine I am
they're pro-free speech good for that
I've consistently seen articles from
them where they they say outright we
should not tolerate the censorship and
things like that and I'm like hey man
look I don't got to agree with the
Socialist if we agree on respecting each
other's right to speak then I'll take
what I can get right now you've got
following the FBI raids a bunch of MTG
margin Taylor green she I guess she's
selling merch I'm not entirely sure but
it says like defund the FBI Crowder has
called for something similar The
Washington Post random story is saying
the right now wants to defund law
enforcement and leftists are laughing
and I'm like bro this was your position
shouldn't you be cheering shouldn't you
be like what happened yeah yeah what
happened what happened is that their
opponents are getting the punishment I
know they enjoy it another problem is
that like censorship's important in the
right context you don't want to allow
people to make imminent threats of
violence it's illegal under the first
time already illegal yeah that's illegal
as a form of censorship and pictures of
children yeah stuff like that you censor
that stuff
um but corporations now are in control
of the Public Square with alphabet and
and meta and things like that where they
can more or less terminate your access
to the masses
um and people the law has yet to catch
up to that I don't think that private
companies should be overriding the first
amendment in the United States so I I
advocate that we free the software code
of large social networks so that other
people can spin up networks that can
interoperate with them and it will see
sees the means of production uh free the
means of production
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there